NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS METAPHOR
PLEASE CALL ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN FONG.
FRAZIER. FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN. LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN. MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD.
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE FOR
TODAY'S IN. WHICH WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA REVENUES TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
TO LOVE IS TO REALIZE THAT WHAT
IS LOVE. CAN BE LOST.
I RECENTLY WATCHED A SPECIAL
SEGMENT ON KYLE KORVER. FORWARD
FOR THE CLEVELAND CAVALIERS.
HE IS THE OLDEST OF FOUR
BROTHERS.
JUST BEFORE THE PLAYOFFS WOULD
DO TO BEGIN. HIS YOUNGER BROTHER
BY TEN YEARS KURT. DEVELOPED
MULTI ORGAN FAILURE.
HE RETURNED HOME TO IOWA TO BE
WITH HIS FAMILY.
WITHIN SIX DAYS CURRENT PASSED
AWAY.
THE UNEXPECTED LOSS OF HIS
YOUNGER BROTHER WAS DEVASTATING.
KYLE KORVER RETURNED TO HELP IN
THE PLAYOFF RUN. THAT BROUGHT TO
HAVE THE LEADERS TO THE NBA
FINALS.
KYLE KORVER CLOSE THAT INTERVIEW
SPEAKING THROUGH HIS PAIN
SHARING.
THAT IS LIKE NOTHING ELSE.
IT GIVES YOU DIFFERENT EYES FOR
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WORLD AND
WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND WHAT
MATTERS.
THE MEMBERS OF THE CORPORATE
FAMILY ARE LIVING KNOW WITH
WISDOM EYES OPEN.
THEY KNOW THAT TO LOVE IS TO
REALIZE THAT WHAT IS LOVE CAN BE
LOST.
IN I KNOW THAT THE THREE
BROTHERS THAT REMAIN. WILL
APPRECIATE EVERY FAMILY
GATHERING JUST BEING TOGETHER.
AS THEY ALSO FEEL A DEEP VOID
THAT ONLY THEIR BABY BROTHER'S
LIFE COULD FULFILL.
WE NEED NOT WAIT FOR LOS TOO
AGAIN OPEN OUR WISDOM I.
AND WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN WE
CANNOT HELP BUT EMBRACE EACH NEW
DAY.
SEEN AS KYLE KORVER SAID. WHAT'S
IMPORTANT.
AND WHAT MATTERS.
NOW MORE ME DOWN. WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND.
THANK YOU INVITE YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG READY BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
REPUBLICAN.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY MAY TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN BE SOMEONE
AT ONE PM ON WRAL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESENTED TO CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
MULLIN FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM DALY
FONG STEIN WORTH FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DALY AND
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MOVING NOW PROMOTIONS.
SO MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY ONE
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN AID
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY
SHOULD HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE OR.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PERMIT THE BUDGET CONFEREES
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TING ARAMBULA
BLOOM CHáVEZ AND OBERNOLTE
TO HAVE THEIR VOTES TO ROLL CALL
VOTES TAKEN ON THIS DAY. AS IF
PRESIDENT WHILE THEY ATTEND
BUDGET COME
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR IS PLEASED
WITH THE FOLLOWING BILLS THE TO
THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWO
THE SEVEN SEVENTY NINE STONE
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY.
YOU FORTY TWO RUBIO ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
NINE BLOOM ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR BONTA ITEM
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY THREE TO FIVE
TING. AND ITEM SEVENTEENA. B.
TWENTY SIX THIRTEEN RAYOS
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE. S. B. THIRTY LOT OF
FROM THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
S. B. ONCE EVERY FIVE REQUIRE
FROM THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE SP FOUR
SIXTY THREE LARA FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
ONE MCGUIRE FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN.
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO GREAT RECONSIDERATION
TO ON THE FOLLOWING BILLS. AND
THEN MOVE THEM TO THE ENACT FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO GABRIELLE. ITEM NINE
A. B. THIRTY FORTY TWO SENT
THIAGO ITEM TEN AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE KANSEN CHU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I IT IS
MY GREAT HONOR TODAY TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO AN INCREDIBLY.
IMPRESSIVE.
YOUNG MAN AND HIS FAMILY AYE
THIS IS ETHAN UP WEIGHING A
JUNIOR WHO JUST FINISHED HIS
JUNIOR YEAR. AT OAK RIDGE HIGH
SCHOOL EVEN THIS FAMILY ARE UP
HERE IN THE GALLERY AND HE WAS
RECENTLY NAMED ASPIRING
ENTREPRENEUR OF THE YEAR. BY THE
EL DORADO HILLS CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WHAT HE DID WAS THIS
ODD COUPLE YEARS AGO I ACTUALLY
A FEW YEARS AGO HE WAS TAKING A
TRIP TO HIS MOTHER'S HOMETOWN.
IN TAIWAN ANY LEARN TO SOME OF
THE LESS PRIVILEGED STUDENTS
THERE.
AT A LOCAL MIDDLE SCHOOL WE'RE
HAVING DIFFICULTY PASSING A
GOVERNMENT MANDATED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY EXAM THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD ACCESS TO TUTORS. AND
ADDITIONAL EXAM PRATT BUT SOME
OF THE OTHER STUDENTS COULD.
SO EITHER DECIDED WHEN HE
RETURNED HOME THAT HE WANTED TO
DO SOMETHING TO HELP THEM.
I CONTACTED THE MDDLE SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL THAT'S RIGHT MIDDLE
SCHOOL HE WAS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
ALL THE TIME.
AND.
EXPRESSES DESIRE TO HELP. AYE
HE THEN DEVELOPED AN ONLINE
TUTORING COURSE TO ASSIST THESE
STUDENTS VIA WEEKLY VIDEO CHATS
AT NO CHARGE. TO THE KIDS THEY
WERE HELPING SO THIS IS A NOT
FOR PROFIT THAT HE STARTED
ORIGINALLY WITH HIM IN A FRIENDS.
TUTORING EIGHT MIDDLE SCHOOL
CHILDREN IN TAIWAN AND THE
PROGRAM HAS NOW GROWN TO MORE
THAN FIFTY TUTORS HELPING OVER
FORTY STUDENTS FROM TWO
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS IT'S NOW AN OFFICIAL CLUB.
AT OAK RIDGE HIGH SCHOOL THEY'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE STARTING TO
HELP ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY I THINK
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS EXAMPLE OF
WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE CAN DO. TO USE
TECHNOLOGY IN INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND I ASK YOU
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO USE THEM
EVEN
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI OR
RECOGNIZE FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN STEPS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MRS.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND HONORING ONE
OF THOSE SPECIAL PEOPLE THAT WE
GET TO WORK WITH.
AND THIS.
VERY SPECIAL JOB THAT WE HAVE.
IN THIS VERY SPECIAL BUILDING
THAT WE GET TO COME TO WORK
EVERY DAY.
DEBBIE METER.
THE OUTGOING CHIEF CONSULTANT OF
THE JOINT LESSON ABOUT A
COMMITTEE.
THAT HE HAS SERVED AS THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT. FOR JAIL ACCENTS
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
SERVING FOUR CHAIRS DURING HER
FIVE YEAR TENURE.
A NEIGHBOR A NATIVE OF THE
HARBOUR CITY IN MY DISTRICT.
DEBBIE MOVED TO SACRAMENTO IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. MARKING
THE BEGINNING OF HER TWENTY
THREE YEARS OF SERVICE AND THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
I SPENT MOST OF HER TWENTY EIGHT
YEAR PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER WHAT
STATE AUDITOR. EVENTUALLY
SERVING AS THE CHIEF OF LESS
THAN AFFAIRS FOR TWO STATE
AUDITOR'S.
I'M GONNA MISS DEBBIE I KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS BUILDING
UNDER MS DEBBIE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING AND
THANKING DEBBIE FOR HER SERVICE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
CONGRATULATED HER ON HER
RETIREMENT.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS
WHO HAVE ASKED TO.
THIS ITEM.
START WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
YOU MADAMS
MEMBERS
ALSO RICE TODAY'S FORMER CHAIR
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE OUGHT
COMMITTEE.
AND OF THE CURRENT CHAIR IN
THOSE FORMER CHAIRS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY NO DEBBIE'S NO CREDIBLE
ACID TO THE LEGISLATURE. HER
ROLE OF OVERSIGHT HER EXPERTISE
THAT COMMITMENT IS UNMATCHED.
SHE HAS BEEN AN ADVISER AND A
FRIEND TO MANY IN THIS BUILDING.
PLEASE ALSO JOIN ME IN SAYING
THANK YOU AND FOR ROAD TO DEBBIE
WE WISH YOU THE BEST IN YOUR
TROUBLES IN YOUR NEW ENDEAVORS
THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO LIKE TO
ALLAY MY HEARTFELT
CONGRATULATIONS TO DEBBIE.
AYE WELL WAS FIRST.
.
A MEMBER OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IS.
SPEAKER TONY ACTORS APPOINT ME
TO CHAIR THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY
DEBBIE WAS A PART OF THAT.
HELPING A NEW FRESHMEN ALONG
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS AND SO
I WOULD SAY CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR RETIREMENT THANK YOU FOR
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA AND THIRD THANK YOU
FOR MENTORING ME. GOD BLESS YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
VERY PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
UP IN THE GALLERY A ONE OF OUR
FANTASTIC INTERNS IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICE THIS IS HUNTER
HINSON.
WHO IS HAVING A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THE CAPITAL
TODAY WITH HIS PARENTS YOU CAN
ALSO STAND WE COULD WARMLY
WELCOME THEM?
THEY'RE ONE OF THE MANY YOUTH
INTERNS THAT WE HAVE
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHOULD GET TO.
THE PART OF THE GREAT SERVICE
WE DO FOR OUR DISTRICTS AND I
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF HE WERE
HERE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
SOMEDAY HIMSELF.
SO PLEASE WELCOME HUNTER IN THE
HENSON FAMILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEM NUMBERS FOUR THROUGH TEN
OUR CONTINUED.
FILE ITEMS ELEVEN THROUGH
EIGHTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN
MATTER QUICKLY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK
AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER QUIRK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE WILL
BRING MODERN STATISTICAL
UNDERSTANDING THE ELECTIONS
VERIFICATION PROCESS.
THE STATISTICAL PROCESS KNOWN AS
RISK LIMITING AUDITS.
WILL SAVE MONEY IN TIME ALL AT
THE SAME TIME PROVIDING US WITH
HIGHLY ACCURATE RESULTS.
REFLECTS EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS
BETWEEN MYSELF.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND LEX AND ELECTIONS ARE
OFFICIALS.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
AND ELECTION INTEGRITY ADVOCATES
FROM THE VOTING RIGHTS TASK
FORCE IN COMMON CAUSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK BUT APART PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING BACK TO ITEM ONE. A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY
TO HATE CRIMES. THANK YOUR
SUMMER RETAIN YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. IT REQUIRES LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
ADOPT THE POST MODEL POLICY
FRAMEWORK WHEN UPDATING OR
ADOPTING A HATE CRIMES POLICY.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
CHANGES THE DEFINITION OF
DISABILITY.
SO THE BILL HAD ZERO NO VOTES IN
THE SENATE ZERO NO VOTES HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR CONCURRENT.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE BUT A QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING OUT BACK IN FILE ORDER TO
ITEM TWENTY ACR TO TWENTY FIVE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO TWENTY FIVE BY SELLING NUMBER
CHOI RELATIVE TO SECURE YOUR LOW
DAY.
THANK YOU SOME EVER CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS.
DO YOU NATION'S ALMOST A
POPULAR SO SPEAK OUT WITH THE
MORE THAN TWENTY NINE MILLION
CITIZENS.
SUCH AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF UP.
CONTRIBUTES OUT TO OUR
CONGESTION ON THE RULES.
WHICH CAN NOW RESULT IN OUR
INCREASES TIE IN ROLE THAT THE
DEPORTEES ARE AND UP MANY
AFFORDABLE LAW ORDER WILL BE A
LOT CONDITIONS.
IF WE LOSE OUR.
NOTES ARE ARE NOT THE PROPERLY
YEAH.
SECURE DAHLE ONTO VEHICLES.
IN THE MEMBER OF A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. IT FUN HAWKS ARE A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OR DOES SENIOR.
AND THE FOOTBALL STAR FROM WE
HEAR CHRISTEN HIGH SCORE. WAS A
VICTIM OF A TRAGIC ACCIDENT DOT
IN ORANGE.
IF ONE WAS SO RIDING OUR AS A
PASSENGER.
WHILE HIS SOME MUD THOUGH DROVE
HIM TO A PICK UP BY.
A CURRENT LAW ON HIS SO FIRST
DAY.
SADLY. IF DONE WAS SO FATALLY
INJURED.
AND THE LATER PASSED AWAY.
WHENEVER I HAVE THE PIECES OF A
MEADOW. THAT THE CHP BELIEFS I
HAD THE FORUM OFF TO YEAH AND OF
THE VEHICLE.
HIT HIM WHILE IN TRANSIT.
IF FUNDS SO TRAGIC ACCIDENT
MIGHT A BEEN NOT PREVENTED.
IF I INDIVIDUALS SO HAD THE
PROPERLY SECURE ADULT VIDEO CARD
WILL RULES.
ACR TWO TWO FIVE.
RECOGNIZES THAT THE PROFOUND
SUFFERING. OF THOSE ARE HARMED.
BY UNSECURED THEIR OLD SITE AND
THE PROVISO.
BUT REASSURANCE ARE NOT THE
CALIFORNIA STANDS ARE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH HALF.
IN FACT
MIGHT BE ABLE A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE.
CURRENTLY IN THE SENATE OF WOULD
REQUIRE THE.
D. M. V..
TO INCLUDE THE HIGH ONE ROTATION
BASIS ARE A QUESTION ON THEIR
DRIVERS AYE EXAMINATION.
THAT THE CLARIFY SO.
THAT THE DRIVING WITH KIANA
FUNDS SAVE. EXCUSE ME MISS AS A
MEMBER CHOI PLEASE.
REGARD KEEP YOUR ITEMS TO THE
RESOLUTION AND NOT TO ANY OTHER
LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
OKAY BY PASSING A C. OUT TOTAL
FIVE TODAY. A CALIFORNIA WAS
GOING FORTY SIX OUT OF THOSE
STATES.
WHICH AB BROKER BRICKLAYING.
JUNA.
SIX S. SECURE YOUR LITTLE DAY.
I ASK THAT. FIRST ROAD BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. AND THE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
FOR THIS ARE IMPORTANT MEASURE
WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ABOUT A QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE FOR DOCTORS. MEMBERS
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
SECURE YOUR LOW DAY RESOLUTION
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES.
THERE ARE FIFTY CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING
OUT ITEM TWENTY ONE ACR TWO
FORTY TO ADEQUATELY STREET.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING DAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
BROWN'S SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT ACR ON FOR TWO FOUR
WHICH WOULD DECLARE OCTOBER THE
FIFTH AS CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING DAY CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IS
DYNAMIC AND DIVERSE RANGING.
OF FROM SMALL INNOVATIVE TO
LARGE SUPPLIERS THIS INDUSTRY
GENERATES.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT BILLION IN ANNUAL ECONOMIC
ACTIVITIES AND EMPLOY OVER TEN
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S WORK
FORCE.
THESE HIGHLY WAY HIGH WAGE JOBS.
HIGH SKILLED JOBS
THAT SUPPORT OVERALL PROSPERITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
TO HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS INDUSTRY MATTER FACTOR
PANELS ARE BEING PRESENTED ON
THE FIRST FLOOR ANNEX WALL TODAY.
SO TOGETHER WITH THE RESOLUTION
WE CAN CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA'S
BENEFACTOR INDUSTRY FOR BEING
THE MOST INNOVATIVE PRODUCTIVE
AND ECONOMICALLY EFFICIENT IN
THE WORLD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I'VE VOTE. ON ACR FOUR TWO
FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AYE RISES A JOINT AUTHORED THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
SOMETHING WE VERY MUCH AGREE
UPON IS THAT.
MANUFACTURING IS SO IMPORTANT
TO OUR ECONOMY.
BUT IT'S ALSO A SOURCE OF.
VERY GOOD PAIN JOBS AFTER OUR
CITIZENS
AND THE CONNECTION TO I THINK
SHOULD ALSO BE STATED THE
CONNECTION TO. CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
I'M MY OWN DEBT IN MY OWN
DISTRICT WE HAVE.
JUNIOR COLLEGES AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
.
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT PARTNERS WHO ARE
WORKING TOGETHER. TO TRAIN THE
TRAINERS.
SO THAT THESE KIDS WHO CAN LEARN
THESE VITAL VITAL SKILLS AND
THEN GO DIRECTLY INTO THE
WORKFORCE IN THE MANUFACTURING
WORK FORCE.
SO THAT WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A JOB AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROVIDING THOSE
JOBS IN THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY.
WE'LL GET SOMEONE THAT HAS THE
SKILLS.
NECESSARY TO DO THE JOBS THAT
THEY NEED.
SO WE'RE MAKING THOSE
CONNECTIONS.
PROVIDING GOOD PAYING JOBS ALL
THIS WORKS TOGETHER AND I THINK
THE AUTHOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND. LET'S ALL CELEBRATE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING DAY.
AND ALSO HELP SUPPORT POLICIES
THAT ARE GONNA HELP.
CONTINUE THAT INDUSTRY AND
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION IN
OUR STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION MR
GIVES IS REFLECTED REQUESTING
COAUTHORS METAPHOR QUIZ OPEN THE
ROLE.
ISRAEL WAS WERE COAUTHORS UPON
THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR CO
AUTHORS.
FOR CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING DAY.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE. THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING
TO ITEM TWENTY TWO ACR TO FORTY
FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO FORTY FOUR BY SOMETHING
NUMBER BAKER RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA CANCER SURVIVORS DAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY ACR TO
FORTY FOUR TO COMMEMORATE THE
DAY OF JUNE THIRD TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS CANCER. SURVIVORS
DAY CANCER HAS TOUCHED I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS.
WHETHER.
THEY KNOW THEMSELVES A FRIEND
OR LOVED ONE WHO IS.
NOT.
WON THE BATTLE WITH CANCER LIKE
MY FRIEND CHRIS SEARING WHERE
THEY THEMSELVES HAVE HAD A
FRIEND OR LOVED ONE LOVED ONE
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER OR THEY
THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER IN OUR SURVIVORS. OR
NEWLY BEGINNING THEIR JOURNEY OF
TREATMENT NATIONAL CANCER
SURVIVORS DAY IS AN ANNUAL
CELEBRATION OF LIFE THAT IS HELD
IN HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITIES
NATIONWIDE AND AROUND THE WORLD
IN THE FIRST SUNDAY IN JUNE.
IT'S A DAY OF CELEBRATION FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE SURVIVED CANCERS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
DIAGNOSED.
IT DOES PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL PEOPLE LIVING WITH A
HISTORY OF CANCER INCLUDING
AMERICA'S MORE THAN A FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR FOURTEEN MILLION
CANCER SURVIVORS. TO CONNECT
WITH EACH OTHER CELEBRATE
MILESTONES AND RECOGNIZE THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN SUPPORTING THEM ALL
ALONG THE WAY. DUE TO ADVANCES
IN CANCER PREVENTION EARLY
DETECTION TREATMENT AND FOLLOW
UP CARE MORE PEOPLE THAN EVER
THIS IS THE GOOD NEWS.
ARE SURVIVING THE DISEASE IN
AMERICA ALONE AS I MENTIONED
FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE ARE
ALIVE TODAY AFTER BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER.
NONETHELESS SURVIVING CANCER CAN
LEAVE A HOST OF PROBLEMS IN ITS
WAKE.
CANCER SURVIVORS ARE
CONSTITUENTS FACE NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES DURING AND AFTER
TREATMENT SUCH AS LIMITED ACCESS
TO SPECIALISTS AND NEW
TREATMENTS DENIAL OF HEALTH CARE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE. DIFFICULTY
FINDING EMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC
BURDENS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MEDICAL EXPENSES THE LOST WAGES
AND REDUCED PRODUCTIVITY. THESE
ARE ALL REASONS WHY WE NEED TO
BE WORKING TO SUPPORT POLICIES
THAT CAN IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND SUCCESSFUL
RESULTS FOR CANCER SURVIVORS SO
WE HAVE MORE OF THEM IN
CALIFORNIA. THE INCLUDE YOUR
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THIS FLOOR
TODAY INCLUDING ARE A TERRIFIC
PRO TEM WHO.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A CANCER EVER
WINNING THE BATTLE WITH YOUR
FIERCE F. FIGHTING SPIRIT I
MYSELF HAVING BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER ALL THROUGHOUT MY
TWENTIES. AND MANY OTHERS.
WHO ARE LEFT ONES SO COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THINK YOU?
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK WOULD
YOU LIKE OF.
YOU YOU ARE REQUESTING
COAUTHORS MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. ACTORS ON THE
MEASURE.
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
I'M CALIFORNIA CANCER SURVIVORS
DAY.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES THERE
ARE FIFTY EIGHT COAUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY
BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING OUT ITEM TWENTY
THREE ACR TO FORTY FIVE MINUTE
BERKELEY STREET. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO FORTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER ACOSTA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO RONALD
REAGAN DAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBER SAU I RISE TODAY TO INTO
REDUCE ACR TWO FORTY FIVE
ESTABLISHING TOMORROW. JUNE
FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS RONALD
REAGAN DAY.
IT IS AN HONOR TO REPRESENT TO
PRESENT THIS RESOLUTION
REMEMBERING A MAN WHO WORKED
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE SERVING
FREEDOM AND ADVANCING THE PUBLIC
GOOD.
RONALD REAGAN ACHIEVED A GREAT
MANY THINGS DURING HIS TIME IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. AMONG WHICH WAS
BEING THE ONLY PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY
HERE HISTORY.
TO BE ELECTED TO BOTH THE
OFFICES OF GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AS PRESIDENT HE DISPLAYED A
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO OUR
ARMED FORCES AND NEVER HESITATED
TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE CREDIT WAS
DUE.
HE RECOGNIZED THAT THE SOLDIER
THE SAILOR THE AIRMEN AND THE
MARINE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD ARE THE
ULTIMATE GUARDIANS OF OUR
FREEDOM TO SAY WHAT WE WANT TO
SAY WHAT WE THINK GO WHERE WE
WILL.
CHOOSE WHAT WE WANT WHO WE WANT
FOR OUR LEADERS AND PRAY AS WE
WISH.
HIS POLICY OF PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH HELP CREATE A SAFER
FREER WORLD. REVIVING FAITH IN
THE PRESIDENCY AS WELL AS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT REAGAN AND I SHARE A
LOVE OF ACTING AND CONSEQUENTLY
ARE MEMBERS OF THE SCREEN ACTORS
GUILD.
PRESIDENT REAGAN SUCCESSFUL
ACTING CAREER SPANNING OVER
SEVERAL DECADES ACTUALLY
RESULTED IN THE EVENTUAL LIFE
LONG NICKNAME THE GIPPER AFTER
HIS NINETEEN FORTY PERFORMANCE
AS NOTRE DAME FOOTBALL PLAYER.
GEORGE GIPP.
TOMORROW WILL MARK THE
FOURTEENTH ANNIVERSARY OF
PRESIDENT REAGAN'S PASSING AND
IN HONOR OF THAT I WANT TO BRING
UP ONE OF HIS LESSER KNOWN BUT
EQUALLY IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE WORLD.
HIS HAND WRITTEN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR LETTER TO THE PUBLIC
ANNOUNCING THAT HERE BAKED
DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE.
WITH MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S.
HIS ACT OF CANDOR PAVE THE WAY
FOR GREATER PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
INCREASED RESEARCH FUNDING
TOWARD FINDING A CURE.
HIS PUBLIC ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
HIS DIAGNOSIS SHINE THE
SPOTLIGHT ON THE DISEASE AND
LEAD TO AL'S TIMERS RESEARCH
BEING WHAT IT IS TODAY.
I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT THE
RONALD REAGAN LIBRARY IN SIMI
VALLEY WITHIN MY DISTRICT AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO PROMOTE THE
LEGACY OF A PRESIDENT THAT
INSPIRED AMERICANS TO ACT. AND
ACHIEVE EVEN MORE THAN THEY EVER
IMAGINED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT ACR TWO
FORTY FIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE AND ASK FOR THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I'M.
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
UNFORTUNATELY.
TO OPPOSE THIS RESOLUTION AND
WHILE I APPRECIATE THAT
EVERYBODY.
MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW AYE I
A SUFFER EVERY DAY THAT I HEAR
THIS GREAT LEGACY THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO.
.
HONOR.
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS LIKE ANY
FORMER PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN
WAS PRETTY COMPLICATED.
UNLIKE EVERY FORM PRESIDENT HE
DID A LOT OF THINGS THAT HAVE.
REALLY LEFT A LEGACY FOR US IN
THIS CHAMBER THAT WE'VE SPENT
MONTHS IN YEARS TRYING TO AND
YOU.
LET'S NOT FORGET IT.
SUPPORTED APARTHEID IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
IGNORED THE SPREAD OF AIDS IN
THE EPIDEMIC THAT BECAME MAIDS.
THEN HE CLOSED.
STATE HOSPITALS.
IT SERVE THE MENTALLY ILL WHICH
LEADS THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
THAT WE SEE ON OUR STREETS TODAY
SOMETHING WE DEAL WITH TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND THIS LEGISLATURE
TRYING TO FIX.
THE START OF THE WAR ON DRUGS
SUPPOSEDLY.
A WAR THAT WAS REALLY WAGED.
ON PEOPLE WHO HAD.
BASICALLY IN AND SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
FALLEN SICK WITH ADDICTION.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE NOW WE TALK
ABOUT SICK WITH ADDICTION ON
THAT OPIOID CRISIS IN HEROIN.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES LOOK A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
BUT IT WASN'T ANY DIFFERENT FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES WHEN THAT WAR ON
DRUGS STARTED.
BECAUSE THAT CYCLE OF ADDICTION
WAS STARTING LARGELY FROM PEOPLE
DISTURBING THOSE DRUGS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND NOBODY STOOD UP
THEM.
BUT THERE ARE NUMBER REASONS I
COULD STAND IN AND RAIL AGAINST
RONALD REAGAN I DO HAVE TO KNOW
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE MY
DISTRICT WHO ARE HAPPY THAT HE
PROVIDED AMNESTY FOR THEM.
BUT THAT'S.
THERE'S ONE REASON IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE I COME FROM WHERE I COME
FROM AND THAT'S ORGANIZED LABOR.
AND HERE WE ARE ON THE EVE OF A
DECISION BY THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT.
BUT THE RIGHT GLEEFULLY THINKS
WILL DESTROY PUBLIC SECTOR
UNIONS THE JANICE DECISION.
IN WE KNOW THAT WHAT RONALD
REAGAN DID ON AUGUST FIFTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE LED THE PATH
TO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE LATER
THIS MONTH.
HE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
NOT ONLY FIRED BUT BLACKBALLED
ELEVEN THOUSAND WORKERS.
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL WORKERS
WHO JUST WANTED THEIR RIGHT TO
STRIKE FOR BETTER CONDITIONS AND
BETTER PAY ON THE JOB.
AS A RESULT EVERYTHING WE HAVE
TO DEAL IN THIS.
IN THIS CHAMBER AND IN THIS
COUNTRY WHEN CORPORATE PROFITS
ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST EVER TO TRY
TO GAIN SOME SORT OF ECONOMIC
EQUALITY.
BECAUSE THE SLOW DESTRUCTION.
A PUBLIC SECTOR AND PRIVATE
SECTOR UNIONS IN OUR COUNTRY HAS
LED TO A BROADER AND BROADER.
GAP.
BETWEEN THE HAVES AND THE HAVE
NOTS THAT STARTED. THAT STARTED
UNDER THE HAMMER A LOT RIGHT
WHAT IS YOUR POINT OF ORDER.
THE MEMBER IS SPEAKING ABOUT AN
UPCOMING SUPREME COURT CASE
WHICH HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HONORING PRESIDENT REAGAN.
SPENT. WITH ALL DUE RECYCLING OR
IS NOT WELL TAKEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU. WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THAT
THE CRISIS THAT WE SEE NOW
BECAUSE OF INCOME INEQUALITY THE
CRISIS WE SEE BECAUSE THE
ATTACKS ON ORGANIZED LABOR THE
CRISIS WE SEE ON PEOPLE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO JOIN. A
UNION AND HAVE SOMEBODY
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED FOR THEM
WAS BECAUSE OF WHAT RONALD
REAGAN DID TO THOSE ELEVEN
THOUSAND WORKERS.
SO TODAY I'M NOT STAND.
WITH THOSE PATCO WORKERS AND I'M
GONNA VOTE AGAINST RONALD REAGAN
DAY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT.
YOU LOOK INSIDE YOUR SOUL IN
THINK WHETHER YOU WANT TO VOTE
TO SUPPORT THE STATE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER.
A SUMMER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT IS SOMEBODY I
GREW UP IN THE HEART OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHO WHO'S WHO'S PROUD TO SAY I
GREW UP ON?
GOD JESUS AND RONALD REAGAN.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
ARE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT A MAN
THAT BELIEVED IN A BIG TENT
AMEND THE BELIEVE IN WORKING
WITH EVERYBODY TO GET THINGS
DONE FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
SOCIETY.
THAT'S WHAT REAGAN WAS ABOUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE VOTING ABOUT
HERE TODAY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERCY
TO YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IDEA. WOULD LIKE TO
THANK.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH FLORIDA
FOR INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO. FOR
HIGHLIGHTING
THE ABYSMAL RECORD.
OF PRESIDENT REAGAN AS IT
RELATES TO THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE ONE THING. THAT PRESIDENT
REAGAN DID GET RIGHT.
THERE'S THAT HE SUPPORTED AN
INCREASE IN THE FEDERAL GAS TAX.
THAT WOULD FUND HIGHWAYS BRIDGES
AND MASS TRANSIT.
AND AS WEEKLY RADIO ADDRESS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE.
YOU HAVE STATED.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW THIS
MAGNIFICENT SYSTEM TO DETECT.
THEN DEMOCRATS WOULD WORK ACROSS
PARTY LINES TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INVEST IN OUR
ECONOMY.
WE NEED.
THOSE TIMES TO RETURN WE NEED
THAT KIND OF BI PARTISANSHIP TO
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR THAT REASON I WAS SUPPORTING
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER HARPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS IF I CAN
SUBMIT SOME CORRECTIONS.
NO RONALD REAGAN DID NOT SUPPORT
APARTHEID APARTHEID WAS THE
DECISION THE SOUTH OF SOUTH
AFRICA.
NO THE WAR ON DRUGS WAS NOT FROM
RONALD REAGAN. THE WAR ON DRUGS
WAS A TERM POPULARIZED UNDER
RICHARD NIXON DECADES BEFORE.
AND NO.
ON THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH REVISIONIST
HISTORY YOU TRY TO PUT UP IN
THIS CHAMBER.
WELLREAGAN WAS THE PRESIDENT
SCREEN ACTOR'S GUILD.
I AM TIRED IS REWRITING OF
HISTORY BY THE LEFT.
JUST BY FIAT WE CAN ADOPT THE
PEOPLE'S HISTORY THE UNITED
STATES IT IS THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
RONALD REAGAN WAS NOT ONLY
GOVERNOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ONE OF THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
HAD.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE OVER THE REVISIONISTS
AND THE LEFTISTS IN THIS CHAMBER.
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SOME UPPER ACOSTA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ARE YOU
REQUESTING COAUTHORS.
YES I AM REQUESTING CO AUTHORS
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
.
THE I DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS.
RESOLUTION AND LIKE ANY MAN AND
LIKE ANY LEADER IN LIKE ANYONE
IN THIS CHAMBER A WE ARE FULL OF
CONTRADICTIONS WE HAVE OUR OUR.
AND LIKE ANY PERSON WE HAVE OUR
STRENGTHS AND OUR WEAKNESSES AND
YES RONALD REAGAN MAY HAVE BEEN
A AN IMPERFECT MAN LIKE ALL OF
US BUT I KNOW ONE THING ABOUT
RONALD REAGAN AND HAVING HIS TO
HIS LIKE. A LIBRARY IN MY
DISTRICT AND I INVITE EVERYONE
TO VISIT FRIEND OR FOE. OPPONENT
OR PROPONENT GO AND VISIT THE
RONALD REAGAN LIBRARY LEARN
ABOUT MODERN CONTEMPORARY
HISTORY AND A MAN THAT STOOD UP
TO TOTALITARIANISM THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. AND A MAN WHO IS
BROUGHT BACK AT EIGHT EIGHT
PATRIOTIC SPIRIT IN AMERICA WHY
AMERICA IS THAT BE IS THAT SHE
AS THE SHINING BEACON OF LIGHT.
FOR MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WE OFTEN IN THIS CHAMBER
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WANTING TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND START A
BETTER LIFE WELL IT'S BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT RONALD
REAGAN STOOD FOR. THAT PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO WANT TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WARTS
AND ALL.
AND WHY WILL TELL YOU THIS
RONALD REAGAN WAS A MAN WHO
LOVED HIS COUNTRY WHO LOVE HIS
COMMUNITY AND LIKE MUCH LIKE
MANY OF US IN AND I WILL ASSUME
ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM. LOVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
HAVE A PASSION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO I I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A A ROBUST
DEBATE. ON OF THE FLAWS. OF A
MAN.
BUT ALSO I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THE STRENGTHS
OF A LEADER WHO STOOD DOWN
TYRANTS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND
DIDN'T BLINK AND THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE A MUCH FREER MUCH SAFER
WORLD THAT WE. TODAY THAN WE
EVER DID AND I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME A MADAM
SPEAKER AND THIS BODY AND I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR TWO FORTY FIVE AND AGAIN
ASK FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT METACARPALS OPEN THE
RULE FOR. THIS ROLE IS FOR
COOPERS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS RULE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION MEMBERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
I AM KIRKLEES CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE TWENTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THIS.
RESOLUTION ADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA.
MISTER COSTA MOVES THE CALL
.
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MY FIRST ANNOUNCEMENT IS THAT
TOMORROW IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN
LOW'S BIRTHDAY.
LET'S ALL WISH HIM A VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS A SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY JUNE FIFTH NO
FLOOR SESSION NOTES CHECK IN
SESSION
WEDNESDAY JUNE SIXTH SECOND
SESSION THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM
THERE ARE.
THERE IS A BILL ON CALL I'M
LOOKING THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE.
MEDICAL WORKPLACE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I DON'T THINK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES TWENTY EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FIVE.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER CALDERON MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS SECONDS
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTH AT
NINE AM HARM BECAUSE LIFTED